I have very mixed feelings about
gangster squad the film starts off
promising it's got a great cast great
villain great look in great setup so
everything appears right but by the time
it was all said and done and I know I
should accept this film on its own
merits I can't help but feel this film
could have been so much more look I
don't care that it's not LA confidential
I don't care that's not the intouchables
even though some scenes are directly
from the untouchables it's just that
none of the characters the story plot
points were fully fleshed out it's not
that I necessarily wanted a film with
more substance I was actually looking
forward to a film with just pure
entertainment this film is definitely
more style than substance but the style
is really nothing unique the action
really is a unique as a matter of fact
there's nothing original about this
movie as far as substance goes none of
the emotional point seemed to hate the
reason why I have mixed feelings is
because I actually really enjoyed have a
lot of fun but I still felt it could
have been more fun and a lot of the good
things about it or rather forgettable as
much as I really wanted to recommend
this film I gotta say gangster squad got
it wrong
you